unwelcome but expected the coronavirus
has hit the UK it's inside this hospital
in Newcastle where two patients from the
same family and now in isolation and
being treated by specialists NHS staff
these pictures taken last year show a
team in Newcastle training for this very
eventualities dressed in protective
clothing and practicing specific
procedure they're well prepared the
priority for medical experts now is
tracking the movements of the two
infected patients this is about finding
working backwards through all the people
that someone might have been in close
contact with and I would like to stress
that this is people people have been in
close contact with not just passing in
the street or something of that sort
- those are the people who we just want
to make sure that if they had symptoms
we know about it early and that we're
aware of the risk the two patients were
staying in this hotel in York when they
became unwell on Wednesday the building
was put on lockdown as some family
members believed to be Chinese nationals
were taken to hospital displaying
symptoms of this new strain of
coronavirus it's one which is highly
contagious there's no vaccine humans
don't have immunity and the virus could
mutate so it's hard to control signs of
infection include respiratory symptoms
fever coughing and breathing
difficulties but in severe cases it can
cause pneumonia and even kidney failure
good hand hygiene is the best form of
prevention not a word from the health
secretary today only a slight nod to
reassure the public but this is the
country which has been on high alert for
weeks on Monday a man was rushed from
his home in Birmingham to hospital by
medics in biohazard suits after
displaying symptoms he's one of a
hundred and seventy-five people who've
been tested for coronavirus and proved
to be negative the official line is not
to panic but this hasn't stopped face
masks running out in some places across
the UK those people returning from China
not just Wuhan who have cold or flu
like symptoms the advice is to self
isolate and call one one one I think
it's important to assure the public that
we have a lot of experience in terms of
dealing with influenza particularly
recently pandemic influenza so our plans
around managing this are very similar to
those in terms of surveillance and
preparedness and then management as we
move through the outbreak to support
patients and the public at this time the
world is still learning about this new
corona virus which is rapidly spreading
by the day with two cases now in the UK
the race is on to work out who's had
contact with the infected patients
health officials have no idea how high
that number could be Charlotte Lomas Sky
News